ahora que sabemos un poco más de
vectores y escalares tratamos de aplicar
lo que sabemos en algunos problemas
cotidianos en los que tratamos de saber
qué tan lejos llegamos o qué tan rápido
vamos o el tiempo que nos tardamos en
llegar a cierto lugar si alfredo viajó 5
kilómetros al norte en una hora en su
coche cuál fue su velocidad promedio
repasemos lo que sabemos sobre vectores
y escalares aquí nos dicen que viajó 5
kilómetros al norte nos dan una magnitud
el tamaño de cuánto se movió y también
nos dicen la dirección se movió a una
distancia de 5 kilómetros que es escalar
pero como también nos dan la dirección
del movimiento vamos a tener un
desplazamiento 5 kilómetros al norte
viajo una hora en su auto cuál fue su
velocidad promedio hay muchas formas de
definir velocidad una de ellas es que la
velocidad es una cantidad vectorial la
forma de distinguir entre vectores
escalares es que a los vectores se les
pone una flecha horizontal encima con
esto indicamos que no solo nos interesa
el tamaño magnitud sino también su
dirección esto no nos da entender la
flechita de arriba
así que la velocidad es el cambio en la
posición incluyendo la dirección de
dicho cambio de posición o lo que es el
desplazamiento y la letra para el
desplazamiento es ese co2 o flechita
encima porque es un vector y ustedes se
preguntarán y por qué no usan de que es
una letra más lógica para esta variable
y mi impresión es que de ya se usaba
para la derivada eso lo van a ver en
cálculo y por eso se usa ese para el
desplazamiento si alguien conoce una
mejor explicación de esto por favor
compártalo en los comentarios
velocidad es nuestro desplazamiento
entre el tiempo
tenemos algo similar para las cantidades
escalares la versión escalar es rapidez
igual a distancia recorrida entre el
tiempo
estas fórmulas o definiciones son
bastante intuitivas para saber qué tan
rápido es algo simplemente vemos qué tan
lejos llegó y cuánto tiempo le tomo
llegar ahí ambos dicen esencialmente lo
mismo si nos interesa la dirección
usaremos la versión vectorial y si no
nos interesa la dirección pues usaremos
la versión escalar una vez aclarado esto
veamos cuál fue la velocidad promedio y
esta palabra clave promedio es
interesante ya que es posible que su
velocidad haya cambiado varias veces
durante todo su viaje pero por
simplicidad asumimos que tiene una
velocidad constante y esa será la
velocidad promedio tenemos que son 5
kilómetros al norte del desplazamiento
entre la cantidad promedio que le lleva
a recorrerlo
y aclaremos que esto es el cambio en el
tiempo este y este de aquí abajo son
cambio en el tiempo algunas veces los
vemos escritos como 'the y otras veces
los vemos con un triángulo antes o delta
a la izquierda de la tf que significa
cambio en cambio en el tiempo
y nos dicen que el tiempo fue de una
hora aunque normalmente no usamos esta
delta te lo dejamos como t que es la
variable que normalmente se usa
así que esto es igual a 5 entre 1 y las
unidades las tratamos igual que las
cantidades en una fracción kilómetros
por hora
al norte eso es igual a 5 kilómetros por
hora al norte y esta es la velocidad
promedio pero hay que tener cuidado de
indicar que es al norte
si queremos velocidad que es la cantidad
vectorial ahora si queremos conocer la
rapidez promedio r va a ser igual a 5
kilómetros entre una hora que es igual a
5 kilómetros por hora y aquí sólo
estamos dando la magnitud si queremos un
vector debemos incluir la dirección en
el vídeo anterior hablamos de metros por
segundo aquí hablamos de kilómetros por
hora pero qué tal si alguien quiere la
información en metros por segundo pues
sólo sería cuestión de hacer una
conversión de unidades y yo creo que no
nos haría daño trabajar en esto en este
momento si queremos esto en metros por
segundo como lo haríamos
el primer paso es encontrar cuantos
metros recorremos en una hora lo
multiplicamos por algo que tiene metros
por kilómetros y luego así para cancelar
los kilómetros y cuántos metros hay en
un kilómetro bueno pues va a haber 1000
metros en un kilómetro
los kilómetros se cancelan y me quedan
cinco por mil por metros por hora igual
a cinco mil metros por hora y ustedes
pueden decirme que esto es obvio que
cinco kilómetros son cinco mil metros y
que pueden hacer esta operación en su
mente pero al trabajar con unidades o lo
que llamamos análisis dimensional es muy
útil hacer esto cuando hacemos análisis
complicados con unidades menos
intuitivas que las que vemos aquí aunque
siempre tienen que hacer una comparación
con la realidad sabemos que en cinco
kilómetros por hora habrá muchos metros
por lo que tendremos un número más
grande si ahora queremos pasar esto a
segundos tenemos que darnos cuenta que
si algo recorre una cantidad en una hora
recordad menos en un segundo de hecho
uno entre 3600 que son los segundos que
hay en una hora esa es su revisión con
la realidad cuando pasemos a segundos
tendremos una cantidad de menos pero
ahora hagámoslo con el análisis
dimensional
esto lo vamos a multiplicar por algo con
horas en el numerador y segundos en el
denominador y que va a ser esto bueno va
a ser uno entre 3600
esto viene de
que hay 60 segundos
en un minuto
y hay 60 minutos
en una hora
si multiplicamos esto nos encontramos
que hay 3600 segundos en una hora pues
aquí los minutos se cancelan y me quedan
segundo por hora
y lo invertimos pues para tener horas
por segundo al hacer esta operación las
horas se cancelan y nos queda 5000
entre 3600 por metros por segundo
aquí sacamos nuestra calculadora 5000
entre 3.600 y vemos que es 1.388 8 que
lo podemos redondear a 1.39 metros por
segundo que es bastante lento